all right totally different way of
relating
to each other to yourself to the world
um
very peaceful and everything happens
naturally
effortlessly giving an interview to you
i've been speaking for three hours and
15 minutes more actually because i
started recording
later i'm cognizant of your time and i
apologize it is floating
it's flowing effortlessly but that's
what i'm trying to say it flows
effortlessly
my books flow not effortlessly and now i
confess that
giving birth to a book is like giving
birth it's painful it wakes me up at
three in the morning and puts me in
front of this computer at three in the
morning even even if i have to wake up
at seven go to work the next day
um every book it's like a cop
why do you responsibility because
it's like a ball of hot iron that comes
up your esophagus
and you need to spit it out and the only
way to spit it out is to finish it
and and and now now it's easier because
i don't resist it
if that's what's going to come tomorrow
then that's what's going to be
and so let it be so there is freedom
in in what philosophers of ode would say
the slavery to the diamond
and the diamond is that superior force
that forces you to do
things in life as a philosopher oh damon
okay
aristotle had a yeah depends on the
spelling
and aristotle had a daemon who told him
what not to do there are other flaws
socrates sorry and there are other
philosophers that have a demon
that tell them what to do um
so uh surrendering to slavery
towards my demon has been the ultimate
freedom
um so the freedom is not the ego winning
over
stealing the god from the fire stealing
the fire from the gods
and making the universe what it wants to
be that's impossible because the ego
doesn't even exist
it's a psychological configuration it's
a psychological phenomenon in the
in the in the pejorative sense of the
meaning
meaning it's not really there it's just
something your mind is making up
that's what it is so how can it control
the world it's not really
there to begin with how can something
that doesn't exist control what does
exist
so freedom for me has not been achieved
through the mastery of control although
i thought i had mastered control by the
time i was 34
i was the youngest as i think i was the
youngest executive in my company
which is one of the top 50 companies in
europe it's not it was not as
it is not a small company
congratulations i'm not going to name
the company but a very very very large
and important company if that company
ceased to exist tomorrow
you would have no new phones computers
or ipads for at least five years
probably ten
um so i i had that illusion when i was
34.
now i control life now i have money i
have a beautiful house i have a
beautiful wife a great job i have power
you had a wife before you were married i
had a wife before i had
my current partner yeah and my my
ex-wife is still a very close friend
uh we are not enemies at all on the
country but we're not married anymore
um and and then it's like instantly
after i got that promotion
and bought the house in which i lived
today which for dutch standard this is
wonderful large expensive house
and that i thought okay uh now i arrived
now now i have control i have the house
i have the wife i have the money i have
the position the power i have everything
and then it's amazing how life
immediately
cuts your [ __ ] short right um
through illness um i thought
well my wife then and i
discovered a a mass in her breast
and it took two weeks for the doctors to
confirm that it was benign it was
nothing to worry about but during those
two weeks
we lived with the reality that it was
probably cancer
and that was nature telling me you think
you're in control just because you have
a high position a beautiful house and
money in the bank
let me show you what control is i would
take from you what you care
most about or at least i will have you
think
that i would take from you what you care
most about and at the end of the day it
was not cancer she's alive and healthy
today
but the message the message was not was
not lost on me
we are never ever
in control we don't even exist let alone
be in control
you are never in control you are like a
mayfly
you are an ephemeral little doing of
nature
that will stop being done in no time
before you even think boom
it's over thank you and you are you have
absolutely no control buddy and if you
think you have you're in for a lot of
disappointment
and suffering and the freedom i found
was in
hey embracing this bernardo doesn't even
exist
of course he's not in control i am a
doing i am a process
something wants to manifest through this
doing and
as the doing i'm not going to resist it
i'll let it through
and and i and look if it works great
if it doesn't work it's not my problem
either
because the you know the same argument
that tells you
you're not in control also tells you you
do not
really have ultimate responsibility
that's not a license for immoral
or dysfunctional behavior that's not a
license
for dysfunctional behavior or criminal
behavior let me repeat it
it's not a license for that it just
tells you
if you regret anything you're deluding
yourself because you didn't choose what
you regret
either